now what then is the role of the IMF it
seems to me that the taxpayers money
goes to the IMF they give it to the
third world country which in turn turns
her back over to the banks it looks like
and a lot of it just goes directly from
you know the taxpayers directed to the
bank it never goes the third world's on
a computer but that was you know a few
years back i guess it was 83 there was
an IMF bailout they were in financial
trouble there was nine billion dollars
most of that money was necessary to pay
interest you know just to the big banks
that's why the Panama Canal treaty
existed it was a banking deal too it was
Panama was having trouble making their
payments to the banks and they need a
better cash flow the Canal treaty
occurred they had more income now
they're a little or old Noriega isn't
quite so obedient and they're a little
bit annoyed by it all but you know
Trujillo's and then Noriega would really
the hand-picked people from our business
banking industry they had a banking
hanging down there but now Noriega isn't
quite so obedient it's making the
bankers a little nervous I'd like to get
rid of them and so for I haven't been
able to and I think one of the reasons
is he has a lot of he has a lot of
information that he is threatened with
they said if you ever get to closes
we're going to let the world know
exactly how you been dealing with us and
subsidizing our drug trade so I think
he's doing a little blackmail people
who've studied the drug trade say that
if we're not for the collusion and
facilitation and laundering the money by
the big banks the drug trade wouldn't be
able operate they'd have a great deal
difficulty because they literally end up
buying some of these banks and they own
the banks and and they do you know
filter their money through now there's a
great pretense that there's going to be
a lot of crack down on all these drug
deals in this money coming into that
they're going to find out who it is but
I think that's basically designed to use
as an excuse develop this hysteria
against drugs so that they have currency
controls on whom on American citizens
who finally wise up and say hey I can't
preserve my wealth in this country i'm
going to put a couple Krugerrands over
in this over into swiss banks
so they try to take everybody with near
the time of runaway inflation people
want to take the money out of the
country to preserve their well and
that's why they're men doing writing all
these laws not catch the drug dealers I
think that's just doesn't you know a you
know a front I think the real reason is
to have currency controls on the
American citizens because once a large
number of citizens decide to leave this
thing of how many people in Mexico tried
to come here when their banking crisis
occurred you know the government clamped
on you can't take money out they still
did but we we are those weak credit
controls in the 1970s currency controls
trying to keep people Britain had them
on off and on and they'll all they
always resort to those kind of things so
we can anticipate it but I think that's
one of the purposes of the big drug
issue is order to write these laws so
that they control innocent American
people who would like to preserve their
wealth but they could clamp they could
do away with a dope trade pretty fast
they really clamp down on the big banks
but they're the head people in the power
structure that's right but they're not
likely to do this John you've taken a
look at foreign investment in the United
States some of those statistics haven't
you it's startling when you when you
look at it all in one lump sum Ron
you're from Houston and there was a
story recently about Houston prime real
estate there being about thirty-six
percent foreign-owned that occurred in
USA Today a front-page story prime real
estate in Los Angeles 49-percent
forty-six percent something like that
foreign owned we're seeing investments
every day banks being bought commercial
properties farmland and the article that
I saw there was a study released last
month on it that it's the foreign
investment total in the United States
now is an excess of 1.3 trillion dollars
and growing at a tremendous rate we call
it the liquidation sale of America why
is it happening there are several
reasons why it's happening but I think
in a lot of those investments are made
by Japanese Japanese investors I think
it's rather interesting to note that we
had to fight award on too many years ago
with Japan we
everyone to war and now they own not
only a lot of Houston in Los Angeles
they own walk-in Key Beach they won due
to our bad policy what they could win in
war the main reason is it's it's our
sick currency we have a balance of trade
problem but we compound it by literally
exporting a lot of our money through
foreign aid in military aid so even
Japan gets a benefit of 50 billion
dollars a year by us paying for all
their national defense so we sort of
subsidize them and because we're less
competitive in our interest rates are
high I rich was raised eight nine
percent in Japan there two and three
percent labor costs are lower so we
can't compete anymore and that's why we
keep buying Japanese products a lot of
people say well the only solution is is
to write a law and say that Americans
can't buy Japanese car and no foreign
investors a lot of investments country
we as libertarians don't accept that
it's treating the symptom rather than
disease the disease as a foreign policy
where we subsidize these rich allies at
the same time we have a currency this
week we have economic conditions that
have made us non-competitive we don't
want to take away the right of the
individual to buy whatever product he
wants and we don't want to start some
type of walling off of our country and
saying nobody can come and go and people
can't come in I want a right to go out
of the country than this and that means
we have to allow somebody else to come
in here and that's why our solution is
free markets sound money low interest
rates competitiveness free market prices
in labor quit subsidizing Japan a
different foreign policy then I don't
think you would have to where we never
had to worry about the foreigners buying
up this country until recent times until
until we got into these economic
problems but it's curious people who say
we shouldn't keep financing the defense
of western europe and japan and yet it's
those people who are buying American
securities and financing our deficits so
they are your orders yeah so they are
indirectly paying for their own defense
you know there is there's some truth to
that and
I think there's a been a deal to I think
that sometimes they're buying our debt
when it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense but you have to think about again
of this internationalism they do this in
order to maintain their order for their
benefits so even if it isn't to Japan
central bank's interest you know to buy
our securities for a strict economic
they might be able to buy somebody
else's security and make more money they
might be able to buy a Swiss security
might be a better deal but if it's best
for ordered in their eyes I think yes
they will then indirectly that is the
case so I along term we can't pay this
debt so if we owe Japan the trillion
dollars if they bought a trillion
dollars worth of our treasury bills I
think they're going to be left holding
the bag that's when I think the panic is
going to come but it finally dawns on
them that they're holding a lot of lousy
debt they quit buying our depth that
will be the precipitating event for the
crisis and that's when the then the
cartel you know this is a cartel of
central banks and they're working pretty
well together there's a lot of power
there but I think they'll finally break
up the little cartel and they'll get a
little bit antsy and they will buy our
debt and in the panicle start this is
there a potential problem with the
buying up of so much US industry and
banks and land and that is its with
ownership comes control and power so are
we through letting them do this actually
giving the Japanese more and more power
over our econ consistent that's why we
should change our policy that's why we
should have sound money I think it's
very dangerous because we literally will
lose control and that's why I think it's
urgent that we look to balancing a
budget as quickly as possible and
restoring sound money and changing our
foreign policy but if we're concerned
which I think everybody is I don't think
anybody is unconcerned die think some
people come up with different solutions
but I want to not deal with it in the
narrow sense or probably providing some
little rigid rule and say well I can
solve this if we just keep Japan's cars
out of here
we're going to solve our pod it's not
that easy I mean we have to look at the
big picture of the economy the monetary
system the deficits the whole thing put
together in order to solve it means it's
not easy well thank you for sharing your
time with us thank you your your
background and insight and we all got to
look for someplace to go when that big
crash occurs I don't know where it's
going to be but we got to prepare
ourselves we all got to start studying
Japanese hopefully not